đổi có thiên phòng khám hiện đại bật nhất, chương sâu, công nghệ khóc, quy mô lớn đến
mề bệnh nghiệm mếp ngung tại Kowzei. Nha 22 tháng 4, hệ thống bệnh
vĩnh đà qua tâm anh đã đưa vào hạt động phòng khám đà qua tâm anh Kowzei với
sĩ tích gần mề bệnh nghiệm mếp ngung, gần 2 trong phòng chức năng hiện đại. Có thiệt
phục bụng bán nghỉ lời khách mỗi ngày, được khi vọng sế sạm tại khánh nặng chân điều
có sởi tế tại Thu Nô. Năng cao chức lượng dịch phủ trong sốc y tế bán đầu trong
tâm anh Kowzei đã chung tâm khám sử bệnh quy mô lớn tử năng của hệ thống
bệnh nghiệm đà qua tâm anh trên tòan quốc với vời gần 1 nghiệm truyền truy ra. Báo sĩ
đầu ngành và nhân viên ý tế trên đồ cao, đồ đồ tư một trong phần trăm mấy móc,
tế bị mối với vảy đại hàng đầu, đồ bộ với hệ thống bệnh nghiệm đà qua tâm anh.
Tâm anh Kowzei có hai mệt thám triệt khoa lâm sàng và cận lâm sàng, trong đó
đổi bật là nhiều triệt khoa mỗi nhỏ như các cứu tổng hợp, luật quyết.
Lỗi tổng hợp, khám sức hệ thống quốc, khổ chợ sĩ sạm, ai viê, sản phủ khoa,
íi, tiêu hóa, tiêu hóa, tiêu hòa, tình kinh, mắc công nghệ cao, cơ xương khốc,
chân thương trình hiền. Phong khám đà qua tâm anh đã đăng ký thiên tòa bảo hiểm
ý tế tệ tòa dễ trong vệ bệnh nghiệm tại bệnh viện tâm anh Lâm viên.
Hà nội, sử ra đời của phòng khám tâm anh Kowzei, kể thống bệnh viện đà qua tâm anh đã
tham định chính lúc hệ thức khoa trung trung tâm tâm cường chăm sóc su khỏe cộng đồng từ giống.
Tự ra bằng công nghệ cao và ghi phía hợp lý để gần hơn với cộng đồng.